welcome back to pft live jj watt a free
agent as of six days ago one word
explanation for the experience so far
wild that tweet came out of nowhere
yesterday just after lunch time free
agency is wild i don't know what he
means
does it mean that he's fending off
suitors with a stick or does it mean
he's sitting around twiddling his thumbs
waiting for the offers to roll in my
guess miles given the unique nature of
2021 and given that
no one knows how much money they're
gonna have to spend thus they don't know
what their budgets will be
the phone has not been ringing the way
that he thought it would now it's easy
for it to ring with hey we're interested
in your guy it's another thing for it to
ring with we're ready to submit an
official offer
i think that's why jj watt believes that
the experience is wild
well it's it could be that it could be
all the guys that are tweeting at him
and wants you know saying how much they
want him to come play with them or
whatnot but i think you're right that
the phone probably is not ringing as
much as it would be with offers um as it
would be in a typical year because you
just don't know how much you can pay him
you don't know what the salary cap is
and because of that you can't really
budget what you might spend on free
agents versus what you know you're gonna
need for the draft and all these
different types of things so yeah i
think at this point jj watt is a great
name to be out there he's still a very
good productive player uh as long as he
stays healthy i think that he could
definitely help a contender but if you
are a contender and you know he's
available you might say yes jj we're
interested in you
but unfortunately right now we just
can't make you an offer because i'm
sorry we don't know what the cap is and
we have no idea what we're going to be
able to pay you
and that's going to be a slap in the
face for a guy who rightfully viewed
himself as one of the best defensive
players of the past generation
three-time defensive player of the weirs
a year surefire hall of famer and now
he's available and yeah he's 32 and yeah
he's not the guy he used to be but he's
still pretty damn good and it's crickets
that that's got to be unsettling the
other side of it too
we're going to continue to get the
reports of potential interest mutual
interest is the new phrase and i don't
want to be overly cynical here but let's
face it each one of these teams has its
own media operation now if you can
inject into the overall consciousness of
your fan base that you potentially may
be getting a jj watt that's good for
business people are going to be dialing
up buffalobills.com
now that it's out there that there's
mutual interest between the bills and
j.j wadd i know what i would do as a fan
i'd be checking it all the time i'd be
creeping on the twitter page of the
buffalo bills when's the announcement
when are we going to find out what do we
know how much does he want can we afford
it that becomes a little cottage
industry within the broader cottage
industry of of monetizing the coverage
of you as a football team so look the
bills make sense the bills make sense
um the question is
where does he want to go
and does he care about what he makes
this year he's yet to say that like ben
did but i assume at some level at some
how's it not a factor all things equal
i'll go to green bay i'll go to
pittsburgh i'll go to wherever but
things have to be equal first and if
there is one team that's putting a lot
more money on the table
and and there is no sure thing there's
no sure thing all you know is it's a
contender we don't know how the dominoes
are going to fall with injuries and bad
calls and good calls and bounces of the
ball and weird fluky things and weather
we don't know any of that so you grab
the most money you can i got no problem
with that it's the american way so
it's it's just a strange
spot
that he's found himself in the 33 day
head start on free agency is now down to
27
and i don't know that after the first
six days we're any closer
to where we would have been last friday
well i think first of all heck yeah you
know all things being equal that's
probably where he would want to go and
also okay he probably cares about where
how much money he's going to make
wherever he goes but when it comes to
the bills i think that the mutual
interest makes sense certainly and the
one good thing that you know you're
talking about the whole cottage industry
of talking about your team and dialing
up buffalobills.com
they could at least talk about jj watt
because he was released whereas you know
like we saw with john gruden last month
where he goes on richard sherman's
podcast because richard sherman's going
to be an unrestricted free agent that's
tampering right now they can talk all
they want about jj watt on any one of
these
official team sites because it's not
tampering so that definitely helps the
case in terms of drumming up interest in
what it might be like if jj were to join
that defensive line and maybe take that
defense to the next level
the bills can talk about jj watt and
they did the steelers can talk about jj
watt kevin colbert had a chance to do so
yesterday and he didn't here's what he
had to say
we never talk about an individual
a potential negotiation
it's my job in our personnel
department's job to know
when a player gets cut and we you know
who that player is and how could he
possibly fit into this we anticipate a
lot of players
getting cut in the next few weeks as
teams come to the realization of what
the cap
may be and for each and every player
that gets cut
we will we will
put those players into the free agency
group that we know
uh have their contracts coming to an end
and we continue to make
those adjustments um so tj
tj is is our guide derek is with us
whether or not we can ever add
anybody i'd hate to talk about it
because it would be just speculation at
this point
something he said there caught my
attention miles and
i i remember the first time i was in
the a team facilities
whatever whatever the room is the
situation room war room whatever the
whatever the cool word is but they have
the giant board
and you've got all the players by
position on the roster on one side and
then you've got all the positions on the
other side and all the guys who are
available just lined up you know 10 15
deep at every position and that's the
moment where it's like my god these guys
really are fungible and for the people
who are pulling the strings and creating
the roster take one name off put another
name on and those are human beings but
there's nothing like that setting to
just see that they're they're they're
not chess pieces they're checkers pieces
they're all the same right so
the point that colbert made that caught
my attention there's going to be other
guys who were cut so
why are we going to chase j.j watt when
we don't know who else is out there it's
like if you're looking for a house and
you buy the first one you like and then
the next day you open the paper and you
see one
that's two times better and half the
price
and it's too late
so i think the steelers and every other
team before they commit to what they
want to see who else is out there
where's the surprise going to come from
who's the guy that may be available that
we're not thinking of that a team may
decide we just can't work something out
we have to cut this guy so that's the
big it's nothing against jj what
there's going to be other not jj watts
necessarily but there's going to be a
bunch of other guys those those little
magnetic
those those little
magnet whatever i'm trying you know a
little steel pla whatever would it yeah
there's going to be other guys let's
just leave it at that they know who we
mean and and i think that's part of this
that's why they're waiting
okay mike you showed your age there two
times a with calling them the magnets
like they just use computer programs now
man and the second thing no they have a
big board they have a big board with
magnets magnets are involved
there's sometimes they're involved but
the teams i've worked that it's just a
computer program and then you're talking
about opening the paper and finding
another house listing right everything
is online now you don't you don't open
the paper and look for a house you just
i'm aware of
yes exactly zillow trulia all those
places they're great uh but yeah i think
the bigger point is like you're saying
there are going to be a lot of other
veterans that are going to be cut and so
there could be somebody else that
actually might be a better fit for a
team like the steelers than somebody
like jj watt just because his brothers
happen to be on the team and so from
that perspective you're not necessarily
wanting to chase somebody like a jj watt
just because he's a big name you want to
get the guy that is right for you and i
think that's something the steelers have
done historically pretty darn well they
get guys who fit their system and fit
their brand and fit exactly what
steelers football is so
because of that i think you're right i
don't know that jj watt is somebody that
they want to chase
by the way now that i remember it more
clearly it wasn't magnets it was a giant
touch screen so there's that
all right uh let's take a quick break
another guy who we know will be
available in free agency but he's not
free yet as you mentioned earlier miles
as it relates to john gruden but until
then the minnesota wild
taking a look at jj
what free agency is wild minnesota wild
makes sense we'll be back with more pft
live right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports